So, listener, this is the portion of our show called the cold open. Why isn't it called a hot open? Well, because it originated back in the old country. Jesus. Yeah, yeah, yeah. With refrigerator boxes. Welcome to an all-new Smarter. Do you guys sleep with the room blacked out or the shades open?
听众朋友们，这是我们节目中被称为“冷开场”的部分。为什么不叫“热开场”呢？嗯，因为它起源于老家。天哪。是啊，是啊，是啊。用的是冰箱包装箱。欢迎收看全新的《Smarter》。你们睡觉时是把房间弄得漆黑一片，还是拉开窗帘？
That's my opening topic. Hang on, Will. Sean's got some material. Go ahead, Sean. What should we say? What is it? I don't have material. No, I don't.
这是我的开场话题。等等，威尔。肖恩有些素材。说吧，肖恩。我们该说什么？是什么？我没有素材。不，我没有。
Do you? No, I can't sleep with the... I have to sleep with them open because I can't... Still rolling. Go back to one. I have to sleep with them open because I can't wake up when it's pitch black, it makes me really depressed. Okay, I mean. I had a payday candy bar yesterday.
你有吗？不，我不能在……我必须拉开窗帘睡觉，因为我不能……还在录。回到第一点。我必须拉开窗帘睡觉，因为在漆黑一片的环境下我醒不过来，那会让我感到非常沮丧。好吧，我是说。我昨天吃了一块Payday糖果。
This is, hang on a second. This is the second bit. He didn't want to lead with this one because it's not as strong as the first one. One subject at a time. Sean, and now are you checking these off every time you hit one of these? Because I know you wrote these down.
等等，等一下。这是第二个点。他不想用这个开头，因为它没有第一个那么有力。一次只说一个主题。肖恩，你现在每讲完一个点都在上面打钩吗？因为我知道你把这些都写下来了。
No, they're in the back of my head. But truly about the blackout thing, that is something that my wife really prefers. She likes to have total blackout in the room when she goes to sleep. She says she can't sleep with light in the room. And I'm still trying to figure out how she's been able to sleep
不，它们都在我脑子里。但关于遮光帘的事，那确实是我妻子非常喜欢的。她睡觉时喜欢房间里完全漆黑。她说房间里有光她就睡不着。我还在琢磨她这些年来是怎么做到……
with her eyes open all these years. Right? I mean, if your eyes are closed, no, if your eyes are closed, you don't need blackout curtains. Your eyes are closed. And your eyeballs roll up behind, in the back of your head when you're sleeping too.
睁着眼睛睡觉的。对吧？我是说，如果你的眼睛闭着，不，如果你的眼睛闭着，你就不需要遮光帘了。你的眼睛是闭着的。而且你睡觉时眼球也会翻到脑后。
Right, but the thing is I can't, but more than that, I don't want to wake up when it's, like, I don't know what time it is then. Yeah, exactly, it's real cokey to wake up in a blackout room. Yeah, I agree. I mean, we used to go to sleep as human beings when it got dark out,
对，但问题是我不能，而且更重要的是，我不想在天黑时醒来，那样我就不知道现在几点了。是啊，确实，在漆黑的房间里醒来真的很让人抓狂。是啊，我同意。我是说，我们人类过去天黑了就会睡觉，
and we'd go to sleep appropriately at that time because there was no light, and then we'd wake up when it got light out. Yeah, you kind of peek your eyes open, is there light outside yet? No, yeah, it's kind of nice. It is nice to look out the window and see that the day's out there.
因为没有光，所以我们会在那个时间适时地入睡，然后天亮了就醒来。是啊，你会眯着眼睛看，外面亮了吗？没有，是啊，这种感觉挺好的。看着窗外，看到外面天亮了，这种感觉确实不错。
That's what I'm saying, yeah. Yeah, it gets you going. I'm a super early riser, as you guys know, and I like to go to bed early too. So how has that been when you've now moved over there to New York to do your film? Which, by the way, I was thinking the other day, I'm a real shithead for not having reached out to you
我说的就是这个，是啊。是啊，这能让你振作起来。你们都知道，我是个起得很早的人，我也喜欢早睡。那么，当你搬到纽约去拍电影之后，情况怎么样了？顺便说一句，我前几天还在想，我真是个混蛋，居然没联系你，
and asked you how things are going thus far, because you're right in the middle of prep, you're a couple of weeks out from shooting. Yeah, filmed a little thing, a little bit. Let me just ask you publicly, how is it going? How are you feeling? Are you excited, are you nervous, are you pumped? Yeah, I'm really excited, it's been good prep, it's been excellent.
问问你目前进展如何，因为你正处于筹备阶段，离拍摄还有几周时间。是啊，拍了一点点，一点点。让我公开问你一下，进展如何？你感觉怎么样？你很兴奋，还是紧张，还是充满干劲？是啊，我真的很兴奋，筹备工作很顺利，非常棒。
It's been really, really good. And yeah, we're right in the thick of it right now. Can you tell us a couple of your credits before this starts? Of course. And are you acting in this? Are you producing it? Are you directing it?
真的非常好。是的，我们现在正处于最核心的阶段。在开始之前，你能告诉我们你的一些作品吗？当然。你是在里面演戏吗？你是制片人吗？你是导演吗？
Let me go back through some of my credits as self. These are the talk shows? Talk shows. Access Hollywood, Entertainment Tonight appearances. Formerly known as Jimmy Kimmel Live, and so those are their own, and then Jimmy Kibble also separate. So this is your big debut.
让我回顾一下我作为嘉宾的经历。是脱口秀吗？脱口秀。《好莱坞报道》、《娱乐今晚》的亮相。以前叫《吉米·坎摩尔直播秀》，那些是它们自己的，还有《吉米·基布尔》也是分开的。所以这是你的大首秀。
Any scripted stuff? You know what? You know what? You know, I was looking at talk show appearances and I was recently, and I was like, I think I've done like all the different iterations of Conan's show, I think a total of like close to 30 times, same with Kimmel. I think I've done Letterman like six times.
有剧本的作品吗？你知道吗？你知道吗？你知道，我最近在看我上脱口秀的次数，我想我大概把柯南节目的所有不同版本都上过，总共大概有30次左右，坎摩尔的也是。我想我上过大卫·莱特曼的节目大概六次。
I think like it's a lot of appearances on those shows. It's a lot of stories. I'm loving being in New York though, so much. It's been really, that part of it has been amazing too. Will will have something prepared. Go ahead, Will, what about New York that you're in? And I'm just saying, if you find yourself in Midtown and you're looking for some men's fashion, sorry.
我想在这些节目上露面次数很多。有很多故事。不过我真的很喜欢在纽约。那部分经历也很棒。威尔肯定准备了什么。说吧，威尔，关于你在纽约的事？我只是想说，如果你发现自己在中城，正在寻找男装，抱歉。
You're thinking maybe New York might be a fit for you once again in your life to live a little bit more full-time there? Yeah, as you guys both know, I lived here full-time for over 20 years and then moved out to LA and the kids were, the bigger kids were little and it just worked out that that was really convenient and they like school out there and they still do.
你在想也许纽约可能再次适合你，让你在那里生活得更充实一点？是啊，正如你们俩都知道的，我在这里全职住了20多年，然后搬到了洛杉矶，当时大一点的孩子还小，而且那真的很方便，他们喜欢那里的学校，现在也喜欢。
So my older kids are in high school in LA. Maybe when they're done, you can maybe, yeah. I'm gonna do a little. Because God knows where they're gonna go. I'm gonna split some time. Exactly, God knows where they're gonna go. And so I'm gonna start to split my time a little bit between the East Coast and LA and the East Coast.
所以我大一点的孩子在洛杉矶上高中。也许等他们毕业了，你可以，是啊。我会做一点。因为天知道他们会去哪里。我会分摊一下时间。没错，天知道他们会去哪里。所以我打算开始在东海岸和洛杉矶之间分摊一下我的时间。
Start to feather it in. And then in a few years. Or is it feather or is it like you say, braid it. Braid it, braid it, yeah, yeah. And then eventually go full, full time East Coast and back here in New York. I really like it and, you know. That's great.
开始慢慢融入。然后过几年。是融入还是像你说的，编织在一起。编织，编织，是啊，是啊。然后最终完全搬到东海岸，回到纽约。我真的很喜欢这里，而且，你知道。那太棒了。
My guest today appears in pretty much everything good you've seen on the small or big screen in the last 20 years. No stranger to the podcast space. Please try to sound sincere. Start from the top again. I love this person. Okay. My guest today appears in pretty much everything good you've seen.
我今天的嘉宾出现在过去20年里你在大银幕或小屏幕上看到的几乎所有好作品中。对播客领域也不陌生。请试着表现得真诚一点。从头再来一遍。我爱这个人。好吧。我今天的嘉宾出现在你看到的几乎所有好作品中。
Period. No stranger to the podcast space. Where did Will go? He's tying his shoes or something? He's co-hosted one about the band U2 as well as a separate one about REM. His last name is also a first name and he once claimed he can't live without protein bars
句号。对播客领域也不陌生。威尔去哪了？他在系鞋带还是什么的？他还共同主持过一个关于U2乐队的播客，以及另一个关于REM乐队的播客。他的姓也是一个名字，他曾经声称没有蛋白棒，
or a water flosser, Jason. Today, he stars in one of the most anticipated second seasons of his show ever. Something I love. I love them in everything, but this one I really love. That show is called Severance and his name... Adam Scott? Brilliant. Adam Scott.
或者冲牙器他就活不下去，杰森。今天，他主演了他节目中最令人期待的第二季之一。我喜欢的东西。我喜欢他演的一切，但这一部我真的很喜欢。那部剧叫《人生切割术》，他的名字是……亚当·斯科特？太棒了。亚当·斯科特。
Hey Adam! Oh my goodness. Woo! Hi guys. This is very long overdue. I know. By the way... This is ridiculously long overdue. Can I just ask...
嘿，亚当！天哪。呜！嗨，伙计们。这真的拖得太久了。我知道。顺便说一句……这真的太久了。我能问一下吗……
Can I just ask... Is it too late to jump in on that blackout curtains or... No, no, no. Please. We know you're a classic vampire, let's hear it. No, I have no stance, I don't give a shit. Really? Okay. What about Naomi?
我能问一下吗……现在加入遮光帘的话题会不会太晚，或者……不，不，不。请说。我们知道你是典型的吸血鬼，让我们听听吧。不，我没立场，我根本不在乎。真的？好吧。那娜奥米呢？
Good opener, good opener. What is Naomi like, her sort of her bedroom lighting levels? By the way, Adam, you don't have to tell Jason what your wife prefers sleep-wise. Okay, just feel free to say fuck off. Okay, go ahead. Jesus Christ, Jason. Well, okay, just feel free to say fuck off. Okay, go ahead. Jesus Christ. Well, okay, just tell me what she sleeps in.
好的开场，好的开场。娜奥米是什么样的，她卧室的照明水平如何？顺便说一句，亚当，你不必告诉杰森你妻子在睡眠方面的偏好。好吧，你可以随时叫他滚蛋。好吧，继续。天哪，杰森。好吧，好吧，你可以随时叫他滚蛋。好吧，继续。天哪。好吧，好吧，告诉我她怎么睡觉。
Uh, I, no, I, blackout curtains in like a hotel, I can never wake up with the blackout curtains, but at home, you know, for some reason, they don't really have the effect. And that was about as interesting as it got. So wait, so you are using blackout curtains in your home? No, we do have blackout curtains now that you mention it. Yes, but I'm always up early.
呃，我，不，我，酒店里的遮光帘，我从来没法在遮光帘下醒来，但在家里，你知道，出于某种原因，它们并没有那种效果。那大概就是最有趣的部分了。等等，所以你在家里用遮光帘？不，既然你提到了，我们确实有遮光帘。是的，但我总是起得很早。
You have kids, you're up early. Blackout curtains don't even matter. Amanda got up early this morning because she went to a workout class with our eldest, kind of a cute mother-daughter thing. But anyway, so she's up early before I'm getting up and I was reminded once again, she's a real heavy walker. She doesn't roll the heel to the toe. It's almost like she's got no flexibility in her Achilles tendon. So she's just jamming the peg of heel down Achilles and she she pops the light switches You know you could turn on a light switch so it makes no sound. Oh, yeah, she's never heard just whack whack
你有孩子，你起得早。遮光帘根本没关系。阿曼达今天早上起得很早，因为她和我们的大女儿去上健身课了，算是母女间可爱的互动。但总之，她在我也起床之前就起来了，我再次被提醒，她走路声音真的很重。她不是脚后跟到脚尖着地。几乎就像她的跟腱没有弹性一样。所以她只是把脚后跟的钉子重重地踩下去，然后她会啪嗒啪嗒地按电灯开关。你知道你可以轻轻按电灯开关，这样就不会有声音了。哦，是的，她从来没听过，就是啪啪。
She'll brush her teeth and Shake out all the supplements from the bottles and stuff from the bathroom It's like what is going on? It sounds like she wants you to wake up. Exactly. How about a nice little reach over and just a gentle rocking would be nice. JB, it also sounds like you are intolerable as a person.
她刷牙时会把瓶子里的补充剂摇出来，之类的，在浴室里。就像发生了什么事？听起来她想让你醒过来。没错。来个温柔的拥抱，轻轻摇晃一下不是很好吗？JB，听起来你也是个让人难以忍受的人。
You are tough to live with. It's fucked up. Because all this time I thought Amanda was the problem. I agreed with you over the years. I agree that she talks a lot. She talks out of turn. She grabs everybody and whispers in their ear. She's always confiding in people.
你很难相处。这太糟糕了。因为一直以来我都以为阿曼达是问题所在。这些年来我一直同意你的看法。我同意她话很多。她说话不分场合。她抓住每个人在他们耳边窃窃私语。她总是向别人吐露心声。
Yes, talk all day. You know, she grabs you, she pulls you to the side. Totally. So she does. Oh, Adam's fell down the hole himself. But now I realize you're the problem. It's not her. She's an angel.
是的，整天说个不停。你知道，她抓住你，把你拉到一边。完全正确。所以她确实这样。哦，亚当自己也掉进坑里了。但现在我意识到你才是问题所在。不是她。她是天使。
As you would say, a sweet angel. Yeah, sweet baby angel. Yeah, no, I've got plenty of quirks. Yeah. Fuck. Adam, welcome. Welcome, Adam. Thank you, thanks you guys.
正如你会说的，甜美的小天使。是啊，甜美的小宝贝天使。是啊，不，我有很多怪癖。是啊。该死。亚当，欢迎。欢迎，亚当。谢谢，谢谢你们。
So, sorry I was late. No, by the way, the, you know. By the way, all of the, you guys were, there was a whole flurry of activity around you being, what, seven minutes late. It's actually impressive. No, it's just unusual. If you're 60 seconds late to this thing,
抱歉我迟到了。不，顺便说一句，那个，你知道。顺便说一句，你们所有人，有一阵关于你迟到了，什么，七分钟的骚动。这其实令人印象深刻。不，这只是不寻常。如果你在这件事上迟到60秒，
one of us will get after you. Oh yeah. Will and I have wrecked each other's days at least a half a dozen times. We're like legit mad at each other and have to have a follow-up phone call four hours later and make up. Because of like a four minute thing.
我们其中一个就会找你麻烦。哦，是的。威尔和我至少有六次毁了对方的一天。我们就像真的生对方的气，四个小时后不得不打个后续电话和好。因为四分钟的事情。
Yeah, there's like 10 minutes of vibe throughout the starting. And they're like, oh, you're mad at me because I'm late? Well, I'm fucking telling you. You didn't want to check your connection before the start of the recording. Wow. Yeah, yeah, it gets real.
是啊，开始的时候有10分钟的氛围。然后他们说，哦，你因为我迟到而生我的气？好吧，我他妈告诉你。你开始录音前不想检查一下连接。哇。是啊，是啊，这变得很真实。
You know how brothers kiss. Sure. You know how that happens. Anyway, sorry, it gets real. You know how brothers kiss. Sure. You know how that happens. Anyway, sorry. Wait, Adam, thank you for being here. And I- Thanks for having me, guys. Yeah, and I'm glad you're my guest because I, as you know, I'm a big fan.
你知道兄弟们是怎么亲吻的。当然。你知道那是怎么发生的。总之，抱歉，这变得很真实。你知道兄弟们是怎么亲吻的。当然。你知道那是怎么发生的。总之，抱歉。等等，亚当，谢谢你来到这里。而且我——谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。是啊，我很高兴你是我的嘉宾，因为我，如你所知，我是你的忠实粉丝。
You know what, I'm glad you're his guest too, to a degree, but I saw the ads for, and I loved Severance, I haven't watched, I love Severance Season One. So good. First of all, out of the gate, you're fucking great, Adam. Severance One. Severance One one. First of all, out of the gate, you're fucking great at it, Adam. Severance one, so good. Love it, love it, love it.
你知道吗，我也很高兴你是他的嘉宾，在某种程度上，但我看到了广告，我喜欢《人生切割术》，我还没看，我喜欢《人生切割术》第一季。太棒了。首先，一开场，你他妈太棒了，亚当。《人生切割术》第一季。《人生切割术》第一季。首先，一开场，你他妈太棒了，亚当。《人生切割术》第一季，太棒了。喜欢，喜欢，喜欢。
And I saw an ad for season two, I don't know if it was on, maybe it was online or something, and I saw an ad and I thought, how have we not had Adam on the show yet? And look, here we are, here we are. And it's Sean's fault. Sean hasn't been able to book him.
我看到了第二季的广告，我不知道它是在哪里，也许是在网上什么的，我看到了广告，我想，我们怎么还没请亚当上节目呢？看，我们在这儿，我们在这儿。这是肖恩的错。肖恩一直没能预约到他。
That was three days ago, I thought, I went through that thought process. Only three days ago. Sean finally booked me. I know. And then, Adam, we don't need to mention the product, but did I hear your voice on a campaign a couple of days ago on TV? Yeah, maybe.
那是三天前，我想，我经历了那个思考过程。才三天前。肖恩终于预约到了我。我知道。然后，亚当，我们不需要提到产品，但我几天前在电视上听到你的声音了吗？是啊，也许吧。
Are you doing any voiceover work for a... Financial... You can mention... You can mention... What is it? Tax act. Yeah. Tax act. You can mention them, you can mention, what is it? Tax act. Yeah, you have a very pleasant voice. By the way, that's my first time delving into that kind of,
你在做任何配音工作吗，为了一个……金融……你可以提到……你可以提到……是什么？Tax Act。是啊。Tax Act。你可以提到他们，你可以提到，是什么？Tax Act。是啊，你的声音非常好听。顺便说一句，那是我第一次深入研究那种，
and it is the best. It's like morons could do it, isn't that right, Will? Will, hey Will. Oh, Will. Like my screen froze, sorry. Yeah, that's what happens when you're a robot you glitch out every once in a while You know what professional grades you fucking I'm not gonna give it away for free. Listen, my friends over the GMC That's made here this American made and if you like a truck
而且它是最好的。就像白痴都能做一样，不是吗，威尔？威尔，嘿，威尔。哦，威尔。就像我的屏幕冻结了，抱歉。是啊，当你是个机器人时就会发生这种情况，你偶尔会出故障。你知道什么专业等级，你他妈的，我不会免费送出去。听着，我在GMC的朋友们，这是美国制造的，如果你喜欢卡车
Right, but you've been doing it like at home for you like you you know Well, you know exactly what you're doing here. Like this is what you've been doing for a long time. Oh yeah. Yes, that is true. It is the best. Ask him what his favorite microphone is and the best cans to wear.
对，但你一直在家里做，就像你，你知道，好吧，你完全知道你在做什么。就像这是你长期以来一直在做的事情。哦，是的。是的，那是真的。它是最好的。问问他最喜欢的麦克风是什么，以及戴什么耳机最好。
I mean, look, do you want to see something? Yeah, do you have a different mic depending on? Oh, that's in a box. Look at that, it's in a beautiful quilted box. Nobody cares about your microphone in a box. Look at that, it's in a beautiful box. A quilted box. Nobody cares about your microphone in a box. A mahogany... It's wrapped up like a precious dildo. Are you kidding?
我是说，看，你想看点东西吗？是啊，你有不同的麦克风取决于？哦，那在盒子里。看那个，它在一个漂亮的绗缝盒子里。没人关心你盒子里的麦克风。看那个，它在一个漂亮的盒子里。一个绗缝盒子。没人关心你盒子里的麦克风。一个红木……它被包裹得像个珍贵的假阳具。你在开玩笑吗？
It does look like that. This is an old school microphone. It is the fucking Cadillac of microphones. This is a, or it's a, you know, a Yukon XL Denali of microphones. There you go, good to see you. It's the Neumann U87. This microphone is made in Germany. I do keep it in this box at all times.
它看起来确实像那样。这是一个老派的麦克风。它是麦克风里的凯迪拉克。这是一个，或者它是一个，你知道，麦克风里的育空XL Denali。给你，很高兴见到你。它是纽曼U87。这个麦克风是德国制造的。我确实一直把它放在这个盒子里。
Germany, we all know Germany, that's where all the good mics come from. Yeah. It is true. Everybody knows that. It is true. Nobody knows that. So Adam. So, yeah, Adam Adam, go ahead Sean, if you wanted to ask... I just wanted to say one thing and then I wanted to ask you something, which was, and I'm sure you know this, but I was doing my Play Good Night Oscar in Chicago with Tramell
德国，我们都知道德国，那是所有好麦克风的产地。是啊。这是真的。每个人都知道。这是真的。没人知道。所以亚当。所以，是啊，亚当，亚当，继续吧肖恩，如果你想问……我只想说一件事，然后我想问你一件事，那就是，我相信你知道这一点，但我当时在芝加哥和特拉梅尔一起演《晚安奥斯卡》。
Tilleman. Yeah, Tramell. Yes, and Tramell said... I'm gonna do it in Italy. I love you to life. I love you to Moscow. Anacora. Anacora. I'm going to do it in Italy next. Sorry, Adam, this is a great rehearsal. We're going to record in a couple of minutes. Anyway, so Tramell comes to rehearsal, and he's like, hey, y'all got to check out my show, Severance on Apple, and I was like,
蒂勒曼。是啊，特拉梅尔。是的，特拉梅尔说……我要去意大利演。我爱你一生。我爱你到莫斯科。Anacora。Anacora。我接下来要去意大利演。抱歉，亚当，这是一个很棒的排练。我们几分钟后就要录音了。总之，特拉梅尔来排练，他说，嘿，你们得看看我的剧，《人生切割术》，在苹果上，我当时想，
oh God, that's homework, I gotta watch another friend's show. And then so I go home and watch, I couldn't take my eyes off. I was like, this is the best. And then every night at the show, I was like, oh my God, I'm in a show with a guy from Severance. It was incredible.
哦天哪，那是家庭作业，我得看另一个朋友的剧。然后我回家看了，我无法移开视线。我当时想，这是最好的。然后每天晚上在演出时，我都在想，哦天哪，我和一个来自《人生切割术》的人一起演戏。这太不可思议了。
So good. He's Milchek for anybody who doesn't know, which now his nickname is Milchek. Which is great. But I want to just talk to you about Severance and get that out of the way because I love it. What, because when Ben Stiller was on the show, he, I think, I might get this wrong,
太棒了。对于不知道的人来说，他是Milchek，现在他的绰号是Milchek。这很棒。但我只想和你谈谈《人生切割术》，把它放在一边，因为我喜欢它。什么，因为当本·斯蒂勒上节目时，他，我想，我可能会弄错，
but he said when he read the script, it was almost, he thought it was supposed to be a comedy or something, is that right? Because there's comedy elements in it, but it's a tone like you've never seen before, which is so hard to achieve. Did you get that from reading it? Well, I think that he was sort of thinking
但他读剧本时，他以为它应该是一部喜剧什么的，对吗？因为里面有喜剧元素，但它的基调是你从未见过的，这很难实现。你从阅读中感受到了吗？嗯，我想他当时在想
a way into it would be like the workplace comedy that we've all sort of grown accustomed to as kind of its own genre. And he thought that could be a way in for audiences, like see these people working with their banter and all of that, except none of them know who they are or what they're doing. And sort of that's sort of the way, and I think that's,
进入它的方式会像我们都习惯的那种职场喜剧，作为它自己的一种类型。他认为这对观众来说可能是一个切入点，比如看到这些人带着他们的玩笑工作，所有这些，除了他们都不知道自己是谁或在做什么。这就是那种方式，我想这就是，
and part of the reason he thought of me is because I've, you know, been in workplace comedy. I was going to say, so as we all know, you were on Parks and Rec for many years, which was... Bravo! Thanks. Thanks, Jason.
他想到我的部分原因是因为我，你知道，演过职场喜剧。我正要说，所以正如我们所知，你在《公园与游憩》演了很多年，那是……太棒了！谢谢。谢谢，杰森。
I'm not applauding. That's fine. I started it down here, just under camera. I see. Okay, thank you. Okay. Feliz. Bravo.
我没鼓掌。没关系。我从这里开始，就在摄像机下面。我明白了。好吧，谢谢。好吧。Feliz。太棒了。
He's saving the parks and the recreation. So... But it is funny, you know. I love that he's in the back of the theater. Oh yeah, yeah. But it also speaks to the size of the, just the breadth of this theater that you're in. Yeah. But yeah, you did, you did a very, a really great, very popular workplace comedy.
他在拯救公园和游憩。所以……但这很有趣，你知道。我喜欢他在剧院后面。哦是的，是的。但这也说明了你所在的这个剧院的大小，仅仅是广度。是啊。但是的，你做了一个非常，一个非常棒，非常受欢迎的职场喜剧。
And then you have to kind of shift gears. I mean, that one is a bunch of people who, they know who they are, but they don't really know what they're doing a lot of the time. That's true. In Parson Wreck. And then you go to this other one, which, and what I loved about Severance early on was,
然后你必须换挡。我是说，那是一群人，他们知道自己是谁，但他们很多时候真的不知道自己在做什么。那是真的。在《公园与游憩》里。然后你去了另一个，而且我早期喜欢《人生切割术》的是，
first of all, is that you're, it's one of those shows where you're, not only do they not know what's going on, the characters, but you as an audience member trying to piece it together, you're like, what's happening? For me, that scratch is an itch. I love that, because it keeps you hooked. You're like, what's happening? I agree, that's part of what I loved about it too.
首先，它是那种你，不仅他们不知道发生了什么，角色们，而且作为观众试图拼凑它，你会想，发生了什么？对我来说，这抓住了痒处。我喜欢那样，因为它让你着迷。你会想，发生了什么？我同意，这也是我喜欢它的部分原因。
And just sort of the gradual, it was a constant like negotiation of like how much of the iceberg do we show, you know, from... First of all, season one, how far are we going to go? And originally the season was, by the time season one ends, it was going to be way further down the line story wise than what it ended up being. So it's constantly that thing, like how much do we want to show?
而且那种渐进的，它是一种持续的谈判，比如我们展示多少冰山，你知道，从……首先，第一季，我们要走多远？最初这一季，当第一季结束时，故事走向会比最终呈现的要远得多。所以它总是那样，我们想展示多少？
How much do we want the audience to sort of follow the breadcrumbs and kind of stuff. Yeah, yeah. But, and you being the protagonist, sort of the central focus, you kind of hold our hand as the audience through this odd circumstance. And you've been the protagonist, you've been the antagonist.
我们想让观众跟随面包屑和那种东西多少。是啊，是啊。但是，作为主角，某种程度上的中心焦点，你作为观众通过这种奇怪的情况牵着我们的手。你当过主角，你当过反派。
Do you like that? Do you like being the audience's proxy through something that is kind of difficult to manage? I do, and it's a completely different thing as I'm sure you'd attest, Jason, because actually early on, I remember when I started doing Party Down, which is before Parks, and thank you very much.
你喜欢那样吗？你喜欢成为观众在某种难以处理的事情中的代理人吗？我喜欢，而且这完全是另一回事，我相信你会证明的，杰森，因为实际上早期，我记得当我开始做《派对之后》时，那是在《公园与游憩》之前，非常感谢。
Thank you, man. Feliz. Yep. Yep. Let's hear him in the back. Baby, you're the little heart of the party. They really love to party. You make me laugh so hard. They like to party down so much. We've never done this bit before and this will be the last time.
谢谢你，伙计。Feliz。是啊。是啊。让我们在后面听听他。宝贝，你是派对的小心脏。他们真的很喜欢派对。你让我笑得这么厉害。他们非常喜欢派对。我们以前从未做过这个梗，这将是最后一次。
But we're just going to go ahead and milk it till it's a stone. They like to party down so much. We party too. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. You're doing Party Down and you're a protagonist or an antagonist? Right. So we're doing a scene early in that show, and we were just starting, and up to that point, I had roles where you're trying to stuff everything into a couple of scenes.
但我们只是要继续挤压它，直到它变成石头。他们非常喜欢派对。我们也派对。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。你在做《派对之后》，你是主角还是反派？对。所以我们在那部剧早期拍一个场景，我们刚开始，在那之前，我有过那种试图把所有东西塞进几个场景的角色。
And so I was doing this scene where Lizzie Kaplan and I were meeting for the first time and talking. And I remember the director, Fred Savage, took me aside after a couple takes and was just like, hey man, you know, you've got all season, you can chill. Pump it, just easy, bro. Yeah, like, we've got all this time, and you can, you know, you're going to be kind of,
所以我当时在拍这个场景，莉兹·卡普兰和我第一次见面并交谈。我记得导演弗雷德·萨维奇在拍了几条后把我拉到一边，只是说，嘿伙计，你知道，你有整个赛季，你可以放松。加油，放轻松，兄弟。是啊，就像，我们有所有这些时间，你可以，你知道，你会有点，
the audience is going to go through the story with you, so you can just pull back and just relax. We use essentially just saying fucking relax. Yeah. Don't worry about it. Did that crush your spirit? Was that shaming? Well, no, it was actually,
观众会和你一起经历故事，所以你可以退后一点，放松一下。我们本质上只是说他妈的放松。是啊。别担心。那摧毁了你的精神吗？那是羞辱吗？嗯，不，它实际上，
it was like the best advice I'd gotten, but also kind of looking back, yeah, maybe I would, in the moment, probably question everything, but looking back, it's like the best piece of advice because he's 100% right, and I'm sure he learned that lesson when he was like nine years old or something, but it's true, you can just take your foot off the gas a little bit, otherwise it's going to be exhausting to watch,
它就像我得到的最好的建议，但也回想起来，是啊，也许我会，在那一刻，可能会质疑一切，但回想起来，这是最好的建议，因为他是100%正确的，我相信他在九岁左右就学到了那个教训，但这是真的，你可以稍微松开油门，否则看的时候会很累，
you're going to be watching someone. Well, you have nowhere to go, all that kind of stuff, right? You know what it occurs to me as you say that, Adam, I'm like, what's the best, can you guys, this goes to everybody, remember a piece of direction, a simple note or something that's always stuck with you that was a good one or a really bad one? I got a piece of bad direction once from, oh gosh.
你会看着某人。好吧，你无处可去，所有那种东西，对吧？你知道当你那样说时我想到什么吗，亚当，我像，什么是最好的，你们能，这适用于所有人，记得一个导演的建议，一个简单的笔记或什么东西，一直留在你脑海里，是一个好的还是一个非常坏的？我曾经得到过一个坏的导演建议，哦天哪。
Don't say the name. Okay, I won't say the name. But he said, what the fuck is wrong with you? Whoa. No, really? I think you said that before, yeah. And didn't he scream it either across the set or from Video Village? No, yeah, from Video Village in front of 200 people.
别说名字。好吧，我不会说名字。但他说了，你他妈怎么了？哇。不，真的吗？我想你以前说过，是啊。而且他不是在片场或者从视频村大喊出来的吗？不，是啊，从视频村在200人面前。
And saying that and then expecting you to like experiment and find. Yeah, yeah. Exactly. Jesus Christ. That was the direction. Also, but Jimmy Burroughs once said, Jimmy Burroughs, the great Jimmy Burroughs, James Burroughs. He said, I said, Jimmy, is it funny
说那个，然后期待你像实验和寻找。是啊，是啊。没错。天哪。那是导演。还有，但吉米·伯罗斯曾经说过，吉米·伯罗斯，伟大的吉米·伯罗斯，詹姆斯·伯罗斯。他说，我说，吉米，这很有趣
or if I like say the line and slam the fridge or should I slam the fridge and then say the line? And his direction was, honey, I don't care. That's pretty good. Jimmy Burroughs wants, not to me, but to somebody else I was doing a scene with. And we're on one of those rehearsal days and he's just got his podium on the wheels. And we go through a scene and we're going to move
还是如果我像说台词并猛关冰箱，或者我应该猛关冰箱然后说台词？他的导演建议是，亲爱的，我不在乎。那挺好的。吉米·伯罗斯曾经，不是对我，而是对别人，我当时在和一个场景。我们在那些排练日之一，他只是把他的讲台放在轮子上。我们经历一个场景，我们要移动
to the other scene, sort of down the stage a little bit. And as he's walking away rolling his thing, he turns to this guy who's in the scene with me, he goes, hey, clear on the words. And the guy goes, which one, Jimmy? And he goes, all of them. He kept walking. He is funny.
到另一个场景，在舞台上稍微往下一点。当他走开滚动他的东西时，他转向这个和我一起演戏的家伙，他说，嘿，台词清楚点。那家伙说，哪一个，吉米？他说，所有的。他继续走。他很有趣。
I fell to my knees laughing so hard. By the way, his book is incredible. Yeah, it's really good. Yeah, it's really good. It's so good. He once just simply yelled to me, stop pushing. That's it? Really?
我笑得跪在地上。顺便说一句，他的书令人难以置信。是啊，真的很好。是啊，真的很好。太棒了。他曾经只是简单地对我大喊，停止推。就这样？真的？
Yeah, I was pushing too hard. Which reminds me of the actual, actually the most helpful note I ever got was very similar, not to drop a name, but I was doing a movie of the week in like the early 90s on CBS with the great Katharine Hepburn. And I was doing a scene with her. And she was... What a talent!
是啊，我推得太用力了。这让我想起实际的，实际上我得到的最有帮助的笔记非常相似，不是为了掉书袋，但我当时在90年代初在CBS拍一部周播电影，和伟大的凯瑟琳·赫本。我当时在和她演一个场景。她是……多么有天赋！
She was our fighter! She said to me, she stopped in the middle of the scene, I was supposed to be crying in the scene, it's just me and her, and she stopped in the middle of the scene, and I'm trying to squeeze these tears out, she goes, stop acting. Wow. And I said, like forever?
她是我们的战士！她对我说了，她在场景中间停下来，我应该在场景中哭，只有我和她，她在场景中间停下来，我试图挤出这些眼泪，她说，停止表演。哇。我说，永远吗？
Should I just quit? No, no, in the scene, just say it, just say the words. Forever. Like forever? Yeah, this is like a career pivot. She was like, she said, no, just say the words, and she was right, and then I just said the words and try to still do that every day.
我应该直接辞职吗？不，不，在场景里，只是说出来，只是说台词。永远。像永远吗？是啊，这就像一个职业转型。她就像，她说，不，只是说台词，她是正确的，然后我只是说了台词，并试图每天仍然这样做。
Love that. Yeah. Wait, so about your first two names. So is this right? Were you gonna be Adam, I can't even say it, Quartararo? Cordero. But first it was Quartararo. Well, my mom's maiden name was Cotteraro.
喜欢那个。是啊。等等，关于你的前两个名字。所以这是对的吗？你本来要叫亚当，我甚至说不出来，Quartararo？Cordero。但首先是Quartararo。嗯，我妈妈的娘家姓是Cotteraro。
And so I was like, well, that's too long. I wanted to, because we have part Sicilian, so I wanted to have like a Sicilian last name when I was in acting school to be more, you know, to sound like Al Pacino or Robert DeNiro. Yeah, yeah, of course. Right? Something with an O would be preferable. Yeah. Yeah. So you got the Cotteraro. Yeah, yeah, of course. Something with an O would be preferable, sure. Yeah.
所以我当时想，嗯，那太长了。我想，因为我们有部分西西里血统，所以我想在演艺学校时有一个西西里姓氏，为了更，你知道，听起来像阿尔·帕西诺或罗伯特·德尼罗。是啊，是啊，当然。对吧？带O的会更好。是啊。是啊。所以你得到了Cotteraro。是啊，是啊，当然。带O的会更好，当然。是啊。
So you've got the Cordarero. Nothing wrong with an Italian name! Exactly. See, this guy knows what I'm talking about. Okay, so wait. So I shortened it to Cordero, and I remember being in the library at the acting school and like writing Al Pacino, Robert De Niro, Adam Cordero and being like, oh yeah, that looks right, that's cool. That's incredible.
所以你得到了Cordarero。意大利名字没什么错！没错。看，这家伙知道我在说什么。好吧，所以等等。所以我把它缩短为Cordero，我记得在演艺学校的图书馆里，像写阿尔·帕西诺，罗伯特·德尼罗，亚当·Cordero，然后像，哦是的，看起来是对的，那很酷。这太不可思议了。
And then what happened, didn't Claire, somebody had it? I don't, yeah, that's right. And it was with a Q too, Cordero. Ooh, I like that. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And then you were like, hey, give me the name of all the Australian pro golfers. That's right.
然后发生了什么，不是克莱尔，有人有它吗？我不，是啊，那是对的。而且它还有一个Q，Cordero。哦，我喜欢那个。是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。然后你就像，嘿，给我所有澳大利亚职业高尔夫球手的名字。那是对的。
Let's see a list. That's the one. Adam Scott, that's the one. Wait, so how did you come up with Scott? What is, is that? That's my actual name. Oh, it is? Oh, I thought that was the other one.
让我们看看名单。就是那个。亚当·斯科特，就是那个。等等，你是怎么想到斯科特的？什么是，那是？那是我的真实名字。哦，是吗？哦，我以为那是另一个。
Oh, fucking great research, Sean. That's... Sean, that was his dad's maiden name. Okay, sure. And so when you were born, you just his dad's maiden name. Okay, sure. And so when you were born, you just took your dad's name? Okay, got it. Wait, Adam, we've never talked about Adam Scott, the pro Australian golfer.
哦，他妈的伟大的研究，肖恩。那是……肖恩，那是他爸爸的娘家姓。好吧，当然。所以当你出生时，你只是他爸爸的娘家姓。好吧，明白了。等等，亚当，我们从来没谈过亚当·斯科特，那个澳大利亚职业高尔夫球手。
Has that been an issue at all? Great swing. He's got a great swing. He does have a beautiful swing. He's incredible, right? I mean, I don't play golf or follow golf, but I've certainly like come up. You could do a lot worse.
那是个问题吗？很棒的挥杆。他有一个很棒的挥杆。他确实有一个美丽的挥杆。他令人难以置信，对吧？我是说，我不打高尔夫也不关注高尔夫，但我肯定像出现过。你可以做得更糟。
Yeah. Okay. To have it, to have it. Have you ever met him? No, but we, I remember way like 20 years ago, we did an interview side by side and something. You have got to. But you guys, he is like, you guys play golf
是啊。好吧。拥有它，拥有它。你见过他吗？不，但我们，我记得20年前，我们并排做了一个采访什么的。你必须。但你们，他就像，你们打高尔夫
and he's still like a great golfer, right? He's very good. Yeah, yeah. He's very, very good. Well, I think it would be cool. Have you met him? I've never met Adam. Sounds like you'd like to.
而且他仍然像一个伟大的高尔夫球手，对吧？他非常好。是啊，是啊。他非常，非常好。嗯，我想那会很酷。你见过他吗？我从来没见过亚当。听起来你想见。
Scott, I like him a lot. He's very handsome. He's very stylish. Why don't you DM him or something, weirdo? Like he's gonna answer me. Okay. But he, but I will say this, years ago, when I first got on that social media site, formerly known as Twitter,
斯科特，我很喜欢他。他很帅。他很时尚。你为什么不私信他什么的，怪胎？就像他会回答我一样。好吧。但他，但我会说这个，几年前，当我第一次上那个社交媒体网站，以前叫Twitter时，
there was a guy who had my handle and by the name of Will Arnett. And it turned out he lived in the middle of the country and he had my handle. Anyway, over the years, people would tag him mistakenly thinking they were tagging me, whatever, and he and I ended up following each other and would talk to each other from time to time.
有一个家伙有我的账号，名字叫威尔·阿内特。结果他住在国家中部，他有我的账号。总之，多年来，人们会错误地标记他，以为他们在标记我，无论如何，他和我都最终关注了对方，并不时地交谈。
Really cool, dude. Okay. Years later, I'm in, you're with me so far? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. This is fun, go ahead. And I went, anyway, I was in Vegas one time and I ended up meeting up with him. We took a photo together, got to hang out.
真的很酷，伙计。好吧。多年后，我在，你到目前为止和我在一起吗？是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。这很有趣，继续。我去了，总之，我曾经在拉斯维加斯，我最终和他见面了。我们拍了一张照片，一起玩。
It was fun meeting another Will Arnett, it's fun. End of story? End of story, sure. What a waste of time. God. Hang on, so but on the way. I so wish I had a story about meeting Adam Scott. You arranged to meet one another
见到另一个威尔·阿内特很有趣，很有趣。故事结束了？故事结束了，当然。真是浪费时间。天哪。等等，所以但在路上。我真希望我有一个关于见到亚当·斯科特的故事。你们安排见面
and you took a photo together? Is that what happened? Yeah. Hang on, dude. You arranged to meet the guy that shares your name and handle on Twitter. He reached out to me because he said, hey, I see that you're in Vegas.
然后你们拍了一张照片？那是发生了什么吗？是啊。等等，伙计。你安排去见那个和你名字和账号一样的人在Twitter上。他联系我，因为他说，嘿，我看到你在拉斯维加斯。
I'm in Vegas. I'm also at Caesar's right now. I said, where are you? And he said, and then we went over and we're like, what's up? After years, why not? That's not bizarre at all. How did he know that you were at Caesars?
我在拉斯维加斯。我也在凯撒宫。我说，你在哪？他说，然后我们过去，我们像，怎么了？多年后，为什么不？那一点也不奇怪。他怎么知道你在凯撒宫？
Because I had posted a photo. Inside the casino, it's illegal, go ahead. Inside, what, do you work for the casino now? I, not anymore. Go ahead. The gaming commission, like what are you? So when you, so, and then, okay, so wait, so now you're, he sees you walking towards him
因为我发了一张照片。在赌场里面，这是非法的，继续。在里面，什么，你现在为赌场工作吗？我，不再了。继续。博彩委员会，你是什么？所以当你，所以，然后，好吧，所以现在你，他看到你向他走来
You don't know what he looks like and he goes well and you turn to him and your eyebrows go up high and then was There a hug or a high five or both Y'all bet you do fucking boring How long ago is this well, this is like ten years ago I bet you know the money you can you, 10 years ago, can you imagine, first of all, A, Bateman leaving his house for any reason, but B, going out into the real world and doing anything with any other person
你不知道他长什么样，他说威尔，你转向他，你的眉毛高高扬起，然后有拥抱还是击掌还是两者都有？你们打赌你们做他妈的无聊。这是多久以前的事了，嗯，这是十年前的事了。我打赌你知道钱你可以，十年前，你能想象吗，首先，A，贝特曼因为任何原因离开他的房子，但B，走进现实世界并和任何其他人做任何事
that wasn't a means to an end that somehow satisfied his ego? Can you imagine? If there was another Bateman, Jason, and he had like a script or something that sounded promising, I'd meet him. Yes, promising sounding script. What a script! I've got a one act!
那不是某种满足他自我的手段？你能想象吗？如果有另一个贝特曼，杰森，他有一个剧本或什么听起来很有希望的东西，我会见他。是的，听起来很有希望的剧本。多么剧本！我有一个独幕剧！
There's a cop named Sean Hayes. Anyway, you've got to meet Adam Scott the golfer. We're putting it out there. At a casino preferably. Oh God, I got to link up with him and take a photo. Sean, there's another Sean Hayes too? There's a cop named Sean Hayes somewhere. All right, so wait, I wanted to know when you first started, first of all, you're the youngest, just like me,
有一个警察叫肖恩·海耶斯。总之，你必须见亚当·斯科特那个高尔夫球手。我们把它放出来。最好在赌场。哦天哪，我得和他联系并拍张照片。肖恩，还有另一个肖恩·海耶斯吗？有个警察叫肖恩·海耶斯在某处。好吧，所以等等，我想知道当你刚开始时，首先，你是最小的，就像我一样，
out of all your family, right? Yeah. Yeah. And have you ever done theater? I've got theater stories, good. Here we go. Good, good, good. No, but Adam, I wanted to ask you though,
在你所有的家庭中，对吧？是啊。是啊。你演过戏吗？我有戏剧故事，好的。我们开始吧。好的，好的，好的。不，但亚当，我想问你，
you're the youngest like I am, and your parents got divorced stories, guys. Here we go. Good, good, good. No, but Adam, I wanted to ask you though, you're the youngest like I am, and your parents got divorced like mine did. Sure. And when you're a kid and you can't vocalize you know, what you're going through, you internalize all of that stress and stuff, and then it comes out later as anxiety. Is that what happened to you?
你是最小的就像我一样，你们父母离婚的故事，伙计们。我们开始吧。好的，好的，好的。不，但亚当，我想问你，你是最小的就像我一样，你们父母离婚就像我的一样。当然。当你是个孩子，你不能表达你知道，你正在经历什么，你内化了所有那些压力和东西，然后它后来作为焦虑表现出来。那是发生在你身上的吗？
Or did you learn how to, none? You were like, oh, I'm glad they're divorced. I have no anxiety. No, I'm sure it did. I don't, I mean, I think, you know, I think when I was so young, like five, I guess, when it happened. Yeah, me too, five.
还是你学会了如何，没有？你就像，哦，我很高兴他们离婚了。我没有焦虑。不，我相信有的。我不，我是说，我想，你知道，我想当我那么小的时候，比如五岁，我想当它发生时。是啊，我也是，五岁。
Okay. I mean, that's pretty young for it to be your fault, but it seems, sorry, keep going. It was clear that it was my fault, and as I know it was your fault as well, Sean. Sure, yeah, I mean that's why I'm here talking to you. But you still have contact with your dad, right? Yeah, yeah, for sure.
好吧。我是说，那太小了，不可能是你的错，但似乎，抱歉，继续。很明显那是我的错，而且我知道那也是你的错，肖恩。当然，是啊，我是说这就是我为什么在这里和你谈话。但你仍然和你爸爸有联系，对吧？是啊，是啊，当然。
Your dad didn't just split. He didn't drive off. See you later. He didn't drive off, and like, you'd last hear like, go fuck yourself! And mother still got both the eyeballs in her? Sean, I actually, as a fan of the show, I really do want to know if you have,
你爸爸没有直接离开。他没有开车走。再见。他没有开车走，而且像，你最后听到像，去你妈的！母亲仍然有两只眼球在里面吗？肖恩，我实际上，作为节目的粉丝，我真的想知道你是否有，
do you have the eye, like? Yeah, my sister has it. My sister has it. Oh, your sister has it. It's her turn. It's seasonal, Adam. Yeah. Have you ever posted a photo of it or anything like that? It's on the documentary. I brought it on stage to show these guys.
你有那个眼睛，像？是啊，我姐姐有它。我姐姐有它。哦，你姐姐有它。轮到她了。这是季节性的，亚当。是啊。你曾经发过它的照片或类似的东西吗？它在纪录片里。我把它带到舞台上给这些家伙看。
He brought it on stage. Yeah, it was, you know, he graced us with it. It was amazing. Incredibly distasteful. Yeah. I've seen that documentary and I don't remember that. I'll have to go back. Just to keep an eye out.
他把它带到舞台上。是啊，它是，你知道，他用它来装饰我们。这太棒了。令人难以置信的令人反感。是啊。我看过那部纪录片，我不记得那个了。我得回去。只是为了留意一下。
It's a loose use of the word. Keep an eye out for it. Okay. Okay, we heard. Wow. It's a loose use of the word. Keep an eye out for it. Okay We heard So we're on question three. Yeah Because we've gone through are you are you are you emotionally scarred from your parents divorce? Yeah, cuz I wanted to know that because I What is it about your wife that drives you crazy What is it about your wife that drives you crazy? And then your favorite of your two children, which one do you like the best?
这是一个对词语的随意用法。留意一下。好的。好的，我们听到了。哇。这是一个对词语的随意用法。留意一下。好的，我们听到了。所以我们进行到第三个问题了。是的，因为我们已经问过，你是否因为父母离婚而受到情感创伤？是的，因为我想知道那个，因为我，你妻子身上有什么让你抓狂的地方？你妻子身上有什么让你抓狂的地方？然后是你两个孩子里你最喜欢哪一个？
Take them in whatever order you want. And then we'd love that theater story. Have you ever had an emotional affair with a coworker? Well, I factored the questions out of them. Didn't I faxed you the questions, Adam, didn't I? Didn't you get that fax? All right, so listen, you fell in love when you were a kid with acting, because you saw the Raiders of the Lost Ark, is what I read, and I love that.
你想按什么顺序回答都行。然后我们很想听听那个剧院的故事。你有没有和同事发生过情感出轨？好吧，我把问题从他们那里提取出来了。我不是把问题传真给你了吗，亚当，我传了吗？你没收到那份传真吗？好吧，听着，你小时候爱上了表演，因为我读到你看了《夺宝奇兵》，我喜欢那个。
Mine was ET, but same era. Sure. Where did you, I don't know where you grew up. Santa Cruz up in the Bay Area. Right on. It's where they shot Lost Boys. Oh, that's right. That's right.
我的是《E.T.外星人》，但属于同一个时代。当然。你在哪里，我不知道你在哪里长大的。圣克鲁斯，在湾区那边。太棒了。那是他们拍摄《捉鬼小精灵》的地方。哦，没错。没错。
That's pretty much the end of that story. Jason, did you ever shoot anything up? They used to shoot stuff in the 80s up in Santa Cruz. I shot something in the back of my knee up there in a cave in Santa Cruz. My friend was going to UC Santa Cruz up there and boy, it came on real fast. No kidding.
那个故事差不多就到此为止了。杰森，你有没有在那边拍过什么东西？他们过去常在80年代的圣克鲁斯拍东西。我在圣克鲁斯的一个洞穴里拍过膝盖后部的东西。我朋友当时在圣克鲁斯加州大学上学，天哪，那东西来得真快。不是吧。
There is a cave though up there called at Steamer's Lane there in Santa Cruz. So you have been up there. He was up there with Leif Garrett. No, I wasn't with Leif on that trip, but there were no needles involved, but there might've been a stinky, skinny joint up there that was tough to stay lit.
不过那边确实有个洞穴叫圣克鲁斯的“蒸汽船巷”。所以你去过那边。他当时和利夫·加勒特在一起。不，那次旅行我没和利夫在一起，但没有涉及针头，不过那边可能有一根难点燃的臭烘烘的细大麻烟。
That sounds like Santa Cruz. Yeah. So the home of the slugs, banana slugs. Yep. And when did you get the acting bug? When you were- Me or was that for the guest? Fuck.
听起来很像圣克鲁斯。是的。所以是蛞蝓的故乡，香蕉蛞蝓。没错。你是什么时候迷上表演的？当你……是我还是那是给嘉宾的问题？该死。
Go ahead, Adam. Boy, I guess it probably was, you know, just seeing movies when you're a kid and you're like, I want to do that, like Temple of Doom and stuff. Yeah. But what made it feel like within reach? Like everybody's got their own thing
继续吧，亚当。天哪，我想大概是，你知道，小时候看电影，然后你会想，我想做那个，比如《魔宫传奇》之类的。是的。但什么让你觉得这触手可及？好像每个人都有自己的东西
where they go like, yeah, I'm going to do it. Yeah. It kind of never did. And that's why, like it was, I know it's like in California, but it may as well be like on the different country or something like we were so far removed from like show business.
让他们觉得，是的，我要去做。是的。我其实从来没那样想过。这就是为什么，我知道这在加州，但它可能就像在另一个国家一样，我们离演艺圈太远了。
It felt like going and being on TV or being in the movies felt like I'm going to go to the moon or something. Right. They came and shot East of Eden and Santa, on TV or being in the movies felt like I'm going to go to the moon or something. Right. They came and shot East of Eden in Santa, like a mini series version of East of Eden in our town. And I remember they like put dirt out on the streets to make them look like dirt roads and had horses and horse drawn carriages and then the actors trailers.
感觉去上电视或拍电影就像我要去月球一样。没错。他们来圣克鲁斯拍了《伊甸园之东》，在电视上，或者拍电影感觉就像我要去月球一样。没错。他们来圣克鲁斯拍了《伊甸园之东》，就像是我们镇上的《伊甸园之东》迷你剧版本。我记得他们把泥土铺在街上让它们看起来像土路，还有马和马车，然后是演员的拖车。
And I was like seven. And I remember seeing that and just being blown away, like holy fuck. And then you went through the American Academy of Dramatic Arts, how old were you when you did that? 18. Was that high school? It was after high school. Okay, okay. And was that down in Los Angeles at that point?
我当时大概七岁。我记得看到那个，简直惊呆了，天哪。然后你去了美国戏剧艺术学院，你当时多大？18岁。那是高中吗？是高中之后。好的，好的。那时候是在洛杉矶吗？
Yeah, in Pasadena at the time. Okay, oh, but then, all right. So then you made a deliberate move to come down and pursue it. And did you drive, it was a classic like drive down there with a bunch of shit strapped to the roof. A bunch of shit strapped to the roof of my 68 Rambler. And boy, what a hard career to start, Jesus Christ.
是的，当时在帕萨迪纳。好的，哦，但是，好吧。所以你做了一个深思熟虑的决定，搬下来追求它。你是开车下来的吗？就像经典的把一堆破烂绑在车顶上那样。把一堆破烂绑在我那辆68年的兰布勒车顶上。天哪，这行起步真难，天啊。
Just like coming in cold and not knowing a soul. Sean tried to do that. It didn't, everything blew off the roof, didn't it? Yeah, me and my sister drove me home from college. Did that really happen? It really did happen. We were super stoned driving home. Didn't want to take that as a sign and hooky-u-y?
就像冷不丁地过来，一个人也不认识。肖恩试过那样做。没成功，所有东西都从车顶吹跑了，对吧？是的，我和我姐姐开车送我回家，从大学回来。真的发生了吗？真的发生了。我们当时抽得很高，开车回家。没想过把那当作一个信号然后掉头吗？
No, because we looked in the rear view mirror and we were singing songs. We both just smoked pot. We were both 18, whatever, around 18, 19. And, or no, out of college, 20, 21, 22. And we just saw all the- I'm just looking at statue limitations here one second. Yeah, smoke them.
没有，因为我们看着后视镜，还在唱歌。我们俩刚抽了大麻。我们当时都18岁，大概18、19岁。或者不，大学毕业，20、21、22岁。我们只是看到所有……我正在看诉讼时效，等一下。是的，抽吧。
You're probably fine. And in the rear view mirror, we saw my clothes flying out, we're just like, do you want to turn back? And my sister's like, nah, I go, me neither. No way, you kept going? The clothes on the highway. Yeah. But anyway, well strapping stuff to the roof is like, nah, I go me neither. No way, you kept going? Clothes on the highway. Yeah.
你可能没事。在后视镜里，我们看到我的衣服飞了出去，我们只是想，你要掉头吗？我姐姐说，不，我说，我也不想。不会吧，你们继续开了？衣服在高速公路上。是的。但不管怎样，把东西绑在车顶就像……我说，我也不想。不会吧，你们继续开了？衣服在高速公路上。是的。
But anyway, well strapping stuff to the roof is like not, you know, and when you're like 20, you're not going to do a good job strapping anything anywhere, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. You don't realize the science. And you're, at that point you're like, fuck it,
但不管怎样，把东西绑在车顶就像不是，你知道，当你20岁的时候，你不会把任何东西绑得很好，是的。是的。是的。你不懂科学。而且在那一刻你就像，去他的，
I can buy short shorts anywhere, I'll just get a bunch of different, right? Like, so, so you, but you move here and then, and then you move to Los Angeles and then you're like, you go to the American Academy and then you're done with that and it's like, okay, as you said, this is a tough way to start. You're like, all right, where do we go now?
我可以在任何地方买短裤，我只是会买一堆不同的，对吧？所以，所以你，但你搬到这里，然后，然后你搬到洛杉矶，然后你就像，你去美国学院，然后你完成了那个，就像，好的，正如你所说，这是一个艰难的开始。你就像，好吧，我们现在去哪？
Was it commercials first? It was background work first. I just moved from school, I moved to Hollywood and just started like going and trying to do whatever and didn't know anyone. And we did a lot of background work and then got like a guest spot on something and then got a little agent and then just sort of, you know.
是先拍广告吗？先是做背景工作。我刚从学校搬到好莱坞，就开始尝试做任何事，谁也不认识。我们做了很多背景工作，然后得到了一个客串角色，然后找了个小经纪人，然后就这样，你知道。
Yeah. We'll be right back. And back to the show. What was the first thing that was like, oh, this is going to give me a little bit of capital that I can maybe use for a couple of jobs. Like, what was the first kind of big thing? I mean, I think part of the self-delusion you need
好的。我们马上回来。回到节目。第一件让你觉得，哦，这会给我一点资本，我可能可以用它做几份工作的事情是什么？就像，第一件大事是什么？我的意思是，我认为你需要的那种自我欺骗的一部分
in order to survive, you think that every time you get anything, you're like, oh, fuck, okay, now. But it turned out that I didn't really have a career until like 15 years later. And what was that? What was the thing that? That was like, it was like this period of time where it was like, parks, stepbrothers, party down,
为了生存，你认为每次你得到任何东西，你都会想，哦，该死，好的，现在。但事实证明，直到15年后我才真正有了事业。那是什么？那是什么事情？那就像，那是一段时期，就像，《公园与游憩》、《非亲兄弟》、《派对之后》，
like this period of like three years where these things all happened. Oh, I see. Yeah, well, you were definitely a working actor that I was certainly well aware of before those three things happened. But you're saying those three things kind of put you in another category,
就像这三年里这些事情都发生了。哦，我明白了。是的，好吧，在你那三件事发生之前，你绝对是一个我非常了解的职业演员。但你是说那三件事把你归入了另一个类别，
or maybe you weren't really auditioning anymore, and you had some incoming calls, yeah? A bit. It was just, I remember when that started happening, and I remember getting some incoming phone calls from like Mike and Polar, like, hey, do you want to maybe, and just being like, oh, this is what it's like to actually
或者也许你不再真正试镜了，你有一些打进来的电话，是吗？有一点。我只是记得当那开始发生时，我记得接到一些打进来的电话，比如迈克和波拉，嘿，你想不想也许，然后只是觉得，哦，这就是真正
have something going. I thought when I did Murder One, I was on top of the world. Yeah, yeah. Thank you. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it.
有事情发生的感觉。我以为当我拍《一级谋杀》时，我站在世界之巅。是的，是的。谢谢。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。
I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it.
我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。
I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it.
我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。
I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. I didn't care for it. How did you, when you were, talk about that, when you were 14, you went to, how did you coerce your parents in letting you go to New York to go, you went to a taping or something? Well, we went to, we went to, we were on like a family trip and I was just like, let's go to 30 Rocks
我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。我不喜欢它。你是怎么，当你，谈谈那个，当你14岁时，你去，你是怎么说服你父母让你去纽约的，你去参加录制还是什么的？好吧，我们去，我们去，我们是在一次家庭旅行中，我只是想，让我们去30号摇滚中心
so I can get a Letterman t-shirt. And we were there, didn't even think about doing the tour or anything, we were just at the gift shop and my brother and I saw Chris Elliott walk by, and we were like, oh, holy sh... And we just chased him down, and he stopped and talked to us for like 20 minutes. It was amazing.
这样我就可以买一件大卫·莱特曼的T恤。我们在那里，甚至没想过要参观什么的，我们只是在礼品店，我和我哥哥看到克里斯·艾略特走过，我们就像，哦，天哪……我们追上他，他停下来和我们聊了大约20分钟。太棒了。
That's cool. It was a great Chris Elliott. Those Chris Elliott bids back from Letterman were unbelievable. So good. And then what was the name of the old man that would always be on the show? Biff Henderson? No, no, no. Oh, Larry Bud Melman?
那很酷。那是一个很棒的克里斯·艾略特。那些来自莱特曼的克里斯·艾略特片段真是令人难以置信。太好了。然后那个总是出现在节目里的老人的名字是什么？比夫·亨德森？不，不，不。哦，拉里·巴德·梅尔曼？
Yeah, Larry Bud Melman. Whose real name was? DeForest Kelly, I think. No, no, no, that's the guy on Star Trek. No, no, no, no, but you're right in the ballpark. DeForest something. I remember when we talked to Chris Elliott, he was talking to us for a while and then he was like,
是的，拉里·巴德·梅尔曼。他的真名是？我想是德福雷斯特·凯利。不，不，不，那是《星际迷航》里的那个人。不，不，不，不，但你猜对了。德福雷斯特什么。我记得当我们和克里斯·艾略特交谈时，他聊了一会儿，然后他说，
I gotta go, but you guys should watch the show tonight. I'm gonna try something new out. And it was the first night he did his, remember he did Marlon, this really weird Marlon Brando impression? Yeah, yeah, yeah. That was what that was. Calvert de Forest.
我得走了，但你们今晚应该看节目。我要尝试一些新东西。那是他第一次做他的，记得他做了马龙，那个非常奇怪的马龙·白兰度模仿吗？是的，是的，是的。那就是那个。卡尔弗特·德·福雷斯特。
Calvert de Forest. Calvert de Forest. So, but what was that like? Because, you know, I think all of us, when you're like Jason, always talked about the first time he did The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson, how like, that you're like, oh God, I'm on that thing
卡尔弗特·德·福雷斯特。卡尔弗特·德·福雷斯特。所以，那是什么感觉？因为，你知道，我想我们所有人，当你像杰森一样，总是谈论他第一次上约翰尼·卡森的《今夜秀》时，那种感觉就像，哦天哪，我上了那个
that all the other famous people are on. So I must be in that, right? So having been obsessed with Letterman when you were growing up, I assume you were on, yeah, many times. Yes, I did it twice before he finished, yeah. I mean, that was doing Letterman, as I'm sure it was for you guys too,
所有其他名人都在上面的节目。所以我一定在那个里面，对吧？所以作为一个从小就迷恋莱特曼的人，我假设你上过，是的，很多次。是的，在他结束之前我做了两次，是的。我的意思是，做莱特曼，我相信对你们来说也是一样，
was a major like life moment. Yes, that's it, that was it. Yeah, totally. Petrifying, petrifying. Everything, I had my brother come out and so he was in the audience. And I mean, you know, it's just the best. And he was so cool and hilarious and I just couldn't believe it.
是一个重大的生活时刻。是的，就是那样，就是那样。是的，完全是。吓坏了，吓坏了。一切，我让我哥哥出来，所以他在观众席里。我的意思是，你知道，这简直是最好的。他太酷了，太搞笑了，我简直不敢相信。
I'm sure I was nervous and terrible, but it was really something. Wait, so why was your nickname Spanky? Here we go. Wasn't your nickname Spanky when you were a kid? Well, it was when I was in Little League, I had, they called me, I was a heavier kid for a few years and I was on the baseball team.
我肯定很紧张，表现很糟糕，但这真的很特别。等等，那为什么你的绰号叫斯潘基？开始了。你小时候绰号不是斯潘基吗？好吧，当我在小联盟时，我有，他们叫我，我有几年是个胖一点的孩子，我在棒球队。
And so the kids called me Spanky because the kid on, went from Little Rascals, the heavy kid on Little Rascals. You know what, I had the opposite problem because I grew up like so skinny, I could not gain weight, I would drink milkshakes and go work out with my brother and eat burgers
所以孩子们叫我斯潘基，因为《小淘气》里的那个孩子，那个胖孩子。你知道吗，我正好相反，因为我长得太瘦了，我怎么也长不胖，我会喝奶昔，和我哥哥一起锻炼，吃汉堡，
and like I couldn't gain weight. Sure made up for it. You fixed it. Sorry, didn't mean to. Walk right into that. You sure did. Yeah, it. Sorry. Walk right into that. Who wanted first? You sure did. Yeah, but it's so funny because people, you know,
我长不胖。你肯定弥补了这一点。你修复了它。抱歉，不是故意的。自投罗网。你确实做到了。是的，它。抱歉。自投罗网。谁先想的？你确实做到了。是的，但这太搞笑了，因为人们，你知道，
make fun of fat kids all the time when you're in school, all the other kids are mean. But like, when I was a kid, people used to make fun of me for being so skinny. People were like, well, you know, Sucks. It was just the same. Skinny shame. Skinny shame all the time.
在学校里总是取笑胖孩子，所有其他孩子都很刻薄。但是，当我还是个孩子的时候，人们过去常取笑我太瘦。人们会说，嗯，你知道，烂透了。这完全一样。瘦子羞辱。一直都是瘦子羞辱。
What would you give to have people make fun of you for being skinny? Yeah, exactly. 100%. And then you played- But the thing is, back then, the kids were all calling me Spanky, but then eventually the coach started calling me Spanky
你愿意付出什么来让人们取笑你太瘦？是的，完全正确。100%。然后你扮演了——但问题是，那时候，孩子们都叫我斯潘基，但后来教练也开始叫我斯潘基
as well, which was so fucked up. Yeah, that's good. Wait, so then you married, so your wife Naomi from my sister Tracy knew me, did you say Sablon or Sablon, right? It's Scott, but yeah, her maiden name was Sablon. When you met her, that was her name, and she was a producer. And how did you meet her?
了，这太糟糕了。是的，那很好。等等，所以你结婚了，所以你的妻子娜奥米，我姐姐特蕾西认识我，你是说萨布隆还是萨布隆，对吧？是斯科特，但是的，她的娘家姓是萨布隆。当你遇见她时，那是她的名字，她是一位制片人。你是怎么遇见她的？
On a show? We met, no, we met at a bar at the Cat in the Fiddle. On tour, remember that place? Yeah, we used to go all the time. The outside so you could smoke. Yes, I used to go all the time. Outside so you could smoke. Yeah, I used to go all the time. We met there in like 1998.
在节目上？我们遇见，不，我们在猫与小提琴酒吧遇见。在巡演时，记得那个地方吗？是的，我们过去常去。外面可以抽烟。是的，我过去常去。外面可以抽烟。是的，我过去常去。我们在1998年左右在那里遇见。
Wow, that's crazy. I was there. We probably ran into each other and didn't know it. I would go there all the time. Same. Like that in the Dragonfly, do you remember? Oh yeah, I would go to Cat in the Fiddle. That's it. Isn't that when you had a candle on your dashboard? Oh yeah. I would go to Cat and Fiddle. That's it. Isn't that when you had a candle on your dashboard?
哇，那太疯狂了。我也在那里。我们可能碰到过彼此却不知道。我过去常去那里。我也是。就像那个和蜻蜓酒吧，你记得吗？哦是的，我会去猫与小提琴。就是这样。那不是你仪表盘上有蜡烛的时候吗？哦是的。我会去猫与小提琴。就是这样。那不是你仪表盘上有蜡烛的时候吗？
Oh yeah. That's just fucking. Those were the days. This is why I don't go out anymore. You know, these guys make fun of me, but I've fixed my ways. But Adam, I used to go to Cat and Fiddle all the time with Julie Bowen and that's when we'd make out and stuff.
哦是的。那简直是该死的。那是那些日子。这就是为什么我不再出去了。你知道，这些人取笑我，但我改掉了我的习惯。但亚当，我过去常和朱莉·鲍文一起去猫与小提琴，那时候我们会亲热什么的。
But anyway, so and then, but you, so it was a. Julie Bowen everybody. Julie Bowen. Julie Bowen, she's the best, I love her. Julie Bohn. You used to have family karaoke nights, and you love Billy Joel. I love Billy Joel.
但不管怎样，所以然后，但你，所以这是一个。朱莉·鲍文，大家。朱莉·鲍文。朱莉·鲍文，她是最好的，我爱她。朱莉·波恩。你过去常有家庭卡拉OK之夜，你喜欢比利·乔尔。我爱比利·乔尔。
Just did a documentary, it's coming out on HBO about him. Oh, you did, really? Yeah, produced it in my company. Oh, amazing. Yeah, Billy Joel. Well, hang on a second. You're... Yeah, Billy Joel.
刚拍了一部纪录片，要在HBO上播出，关于他的。哦，你拍了，真的吗？是的，在我公司制作的。哦，太棒了。是的，比利·乔尔。好吧，等一下。你是……是的，比利·乔尔。
You're a huge Billy Joel. He's the piano man! Ha ha ha! Sorry. So stupid. Just crushing this bitch to death. Wait, are you a singer? No, I can't sing at all. Oh, so you just kind of do it.
你是比利·乔尔的超级粉丝。他是钢琴手！哈哈！抱歉。太蠢了。简直要把这个婊子折磨死。等等，你是歌手吗？不，我根本不会唱歌。哦，所以你只是随便唱唱。
Yeah, I guess so. Where are you right now? What room are we enjoying? This is our office over on Radford. It is on Radford. Did you just say Radford? I did. How did you know that?
是的，我想是这样。你现在在哪里？我们在享受什么房间？这是我们在雷德福德的办公室。是在雷德福德。你刚才说雷德福德了吗？我说了。你怎么知道的？
I don't know, there was something about the bleakness of it that was like Radford. Are you still doing the show, Severance? I thought it was Radford. No, this is, Naomi and I have a company that we have in our office here. Oh, that's great, that's great. That's fucking crazy that I just-
我不知道，它有一种荒凉感，就像雷德福德。你还在做那个节目《人生切割术》吗？我以为是雷德福德。不，这是，娜奥米和我在我们这里的办公室有一家公司。哦，那太棒了，那太棒了。我刚才说……简直太疯狂了
It's insane that you just said Radford. That is wild. They're about to redo that whole studio. Have you been? Consulted about that. No, they haven't asked me anything about that and now I'm pretty fucking pissed Yeah, no, they're gonna redo the whole thing. It's kind of a little prints over and go through it with me Wait, what do you what you what are you excited about? That's coming out of your company? Well, we're developing a bunch of stuff right now. Do you like that kind of work?
你刚才说雷德福德真是太疯狂了。那太狂野了。他们正要重做整个工作室。你去过吗？咨询过那个吗？不，他们没问过我任何关于那个的事，现在我非常该死地生气。是的，不，他们要重做整个事情。这有点……等等，你对什么感到兴奋？从你公司出来的？好吧，我们现在正在开发一堆东西。你喜欢那种工作吗？
Like working with writers and taking a script and? I do. Yeah. I know you do too. I'm sure, I know all of you guys do. Yes, I do. I mean, I think like, and I don't know if it's the same for you guys,
比如和编剧一起工作，拿一个剧本？我喜欢。是的。我知道你也喜欢。我敢肯定，我知道你们所有人都喜欢。是的，我喜欢。我的意思是，我认为，我不知道这对你们来说是否一样，
but after acting for so long, it's nice to use all the hours of your day, because after a certain number of years, you realize that acting can take up this much, but if you're producing or whatever, you can sort of take all of it. Yeah, and sort of keep your eye on the whole thing, the thing as a whole instead of just your little part of it
但在演了这么久之后，能利用你一天中的所有时间是很好的，因为在几年之后，你意识到表演只能占据这么多，但如果你在制作或者其他什么，你可以把所有这些都利用起来。是的，并且可以关注整个事情，作为一个整体，而不是仅仅关注你那一点点
that you can't really control all that much. Are they listening to you at all over there on Severance? Let's get you in trouble here. Let's do it. When you have thoughts and ideas over there at Severance, fun to get there and get involved? Yeah, for sure. Dan Erickson who created it and Ben and,
你无法真正控制的部分。他们在《人生切割术》那边听你的吗？让我们让你惹上麻烦。来吧。当你在《人生切割术》那边有想法和点子时，去那里参与其中很有趣吗？是的，当然。丹·埃里克森创造了它，还有本，
that's great, yeah. Dan Erickson and Ben Stiller. Yeah, it's a great group of people. We have great time. And where are you in that process? You're out here in LA, you're obviously not shooting. You are waiting to hear about a third season or plans to start it? Well, they're not gonna hear about a third season or plans to start it?
那太棒了，是的。丹·埃里克森和本·斯蒂勒。是的，这是一群很棒的人。我们玩得很开心。你在那个过程中处于什么阶段？你在这里洛杉矶，显然没在拍摄。你在等第三季的消息或开始的计划吗？好吧，他们不会……第三季的消息或开始的计划吗？
Well, they're not gonna not make a third season. Yeah, we're hopeful that we'll be able to make a third season. When would you start doing that if they do? Hopefully really soon so it's not, this last break was like three years, a three year wait between seasons. So hopefully it'll be a lot shorter than that.
好吧，他们不会不拍第三季的。是的，我们希望我们能拍第三季。如果他们拍的话，你什么时候开始做？希望很快，这样就不会，上一次休息是三年，两季之间等了三年。所以希望这次会比那短得多。
And that's in New York, right? New York, yeah. And how does that work with... Family. Yeah, do you, I mean, it's a, sometimes it's an annoying thing to hear about us complain about, but it is a real thing. It's not easy to manage working away from Los Angeles
那是在纽约，对吧？纽约，是的。那和……家庭怎么协调？是的，你，我的意思是，有时候听到我们抱怨这个很烦人，但这确实是一件真实的事情。在远离洛杉矶的地方工作并不容易管理
where a lot of the work happens. It is, it's really hard with family because I know you just finished something out there. For Severance, it's like nine, 10 months we're shooting that show. And so it's just like, you know, you're just gone. And I know you try, I try and fly back as much as possible, but I don't end up with much time off.
很多工作都在那里发生。是的，这和家庭在一起真的很难，因为我知道你刚在那边拍完什么。对于《人生切割术》，我们拍那个节目要九、十个月。所以就像，你知道，你只是离开了。我知道你尝试，我尝试尽可能多地飞回来，但我最终没有多少休息时间。
But the kids, the good thing is, is teenagers, they fly out on their own if they want to, and they love going to New York. You figure it out, but it's, it is, it's a drag. It's hard. Go back to, you know, I didn't know all this music, I didn't know you love music as much as I do, or probably Will does.
但是孩子们，好的一点是，作为青少年，如果他们想的话，他们会自己飞过去，他们喜欢去纽约。你会想通的，但它，它确实很麻烦。很难。回到，你知道，我不知道所有这些音乐，我不知道你像我一样喜欢音乐，或者可能威尔也喜欢。
Jason, what do you mean like, like, like, like a- Jason doesn't know, Jason doesn't know what he likes. Jason doesn't care for music. No, he doesn't get it. I like sounds. But you did a podcast- He just goes, somebody tell me what's cool. You did a whole podcast about U2,
杰森，你是什么意思，像，像，像一个……杰森不知道，杰森不知道他喜欢什么。杰森不喜欢音乐。不，他不明白。我喜欢声音。但你做了一个播客……他只是说，有人告诉我什么很酷。你做了一个关于U2的完整播客，
which I didn't know, an REM, and did you meet Bono or U2 or anything? Is that true? Yeah, it was in the intro. know, an REM, and did you meet Bono or U2 or anything? Is that true? Yeah, it was in the intro. Yeah, we did, Scott Ackerman and I. Don't get pissed off, Sean. Scott Ackerman and I. It was in my fucking written intro.
我不知道，还有REM，你见过波诺或U2或什么人吗？那是真的吗？是的，在介绍里。知道，还有REM，你见过波诺或U2或什么人吗？那是真的吗？是的，在介绍里。是的，我们做了，斯科特·阿克曼和我。别生气，肖恩。斯科特·阿克曼和我。它在我的该死的书面介绍里。
We started a podcast about U2, just sort of as a joke, because U2 kind of felt like a funny, funny subject matter just because they're so sort of mainstream. We go and analyze that. We weren't sure what it was going to be, but we just started going album by album through U2's catalog, both of us growing up with them and being fans and stuff. But then, and it's so stupid, it's ridiculous bits and stuff,
我们开始了一个关于U2的播客，只是作为一个笑话，因为U2感觉像是一个有趣的主题，因为他们太主流了。我们去分析那个。我们不确定它会是什么，但我们只是开始逐张专辑地浏览U2的目录，我们俩都是伴随着他们长大的，是粉丝什么的。但是然后，这太蠢了，这是荒谬的片段什么的，
but super fun. But then eventually, and it was not our intention at all when we started it, eventually we did have the band on a couple of times. That's amazing. Oh, that's cool. Which was, yeah, super crazy. Did you see them perform at the Sphere?
但超级有趣。但后来最终，当我们开始时，这根本不是我们的意图，最终我们确实请过乐队几次。那太棒了。哦，那很酷。这，是的，超级疯狂。你去看他们在Sphere的表演了吗？
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, cool, right? Wasn't that incredible? That venue is just stunning. Yeah, it's Yeah. Yeah, cool, right? Wasn't that incredible? That venue is just stunning. That's crazy. I went opening night, I think, like the very first, yeah.
是的。是的。是的，很酷，对吧？那不是很不可思议吗？那个场地简直太令人惊叹了。是的，它是……是的。是的，很酷，对吧？那不是很不可思议吗？那个场地简直太令人惊叹了。那太疯狂了。我想我是开幕之夜去的，我想，就像最开始的，是的。
It was wild. First of all, thank you for being here today. Theater stories. Yeah, well, by the way, if you have a theater story, I love a good theater story. You can tell me now, you can call me later. We're going to end strong right here. I actually don't.
那太狂野了。首先，谢谢你今天来到这里。剧院故事。是的，顺便说一句，如果你有剧院故事，我喜欢好的剧院故事。你现在可以告诉我，你以后可以打电话给我。我们就在这里强力收尾。我其实没有。
All right. Okay, next question. I do. We're going to end strong right here. I actually don't. All right. Okay, next question. I do. So. Finish strong, Sean, come on. You can do this. I want to talk about Billy Joel and why you love him so much because I love him so much.
好吧。好的，下一个问题。我有。我们就在这里强力收尾。我其实没有。好吧。好的，下一个问题。我有。所以。强力收尾，肖恩，来吧。你可以做到。我想谈谈比利·乔尔以及为什么你这么爱他，因为我也很爱他。
I think you met Paul Rudd and you got to meet Billy Joel and you and Paul met him at the same time or something or some story. We had him, I did this thing, Naomi and I made this show for Adult Swim where we recreated opening credit sequences for TV shows from the 80s. That's funny.
我想你见过保罗·路德，你见到了比利·乔尔，你和保罗同时见到了他，或者类似的故事。我们有他，我做了这件事，娜奥米和我为Adult Swim制作了这个节目，我们重现了80年代电视节目的片头。那很有趣。
Shot for Shot made these opening credit sequences. So we did Boos and Buddies with Rudd and I as those guys. That's funny. And it was a Billy Joel song, obviously, was the theme song. And so as part of the like fake documentary about the making of this thing, we got Billy Joel to join us and play the song for us. He was great, he was really, really funny and great.
逐个镜头制作了这些片头。所以我们和路德一起做了《Boos and Buddies》，我是那些家伙。那很有趣。显然，比利·乔尔的歌是主题曲。所以作为关于制作这件事的伪纪录片的一部分，我们让比利·乔尔加入我们并为我们演奏了这首歌。他很棒，他真的，真的很有趣，很棒。
That's cool, yeah. Sean, I didn't know that you liked Billy Joel so much. I love Billy Joel, I know, I play his music, I sing his songs, my go-to is Honesty. I love that song. Oh, it's a great song. Did you see him at the Madison Square Garden? Yeah, because I was about to say bullshit.
那很酷，是的。肖恩，我不知道你这么喜欢比利·乔尔。我爱比利·乔尔，我知道，我放他的音乐，我唱他的歌，我的首选是《Honesty》。我爱那首歌。哦，那是一首很棒的歌。你在麦迪逊广场花园看过他吗？是的，因为我正要说胡扯。
But what do you say? Yeah, bullshit on that. But, okay. No, I couldn't make it out for Madison Square Garden, but I really wanted to, but I've seen him in concert many, many times. Yeah, it's great. Another guy with two first names.
但你说了什么？是的，胡扯。但是，好的。不，我没能去麦迪逊广场花园，但我真的很想去，但我看过很多次他的演唱会。是的，太棒了。又一个有两个名字的人。
Yeah, that's right. Oh, man. Billy Joel, yeah, look at that. Adam Cordero. That's me. Adam Cordero. That's me. Adam Cordero. That's me. Adam Scott, listen, I wanted to ask you, but we ran out of time, we're saying goodbye,
是的，没错。哦，天哪。比利·乔尔，是的，看看那个。亚当·科德罗。那是我。亚当·科德罗。那是我。亚当·科德罗。那是我。亚当·斯科特，听着，我想问你，但我们没时间了，我们要说再见了，
but you must get stopped. People must stop you all the time because of stuff you do, but Step Brothers, people must go crazy on you, right? Yeah, it's still, like that was a while, a while ago. And yeah, people love. I know, but it was so popular. Love that movie. And I love it too.
但你一定会被拦住。人们一定总是拦住你，因为你做的事情，但《非亲兄弟》，人们一定为你疯狂，对吧？是的，它仍然，那是一段时间，很久以前了。而且是的，人们喜欢。我知道，但它太受欢迎了。喜欢那部电影。我也喜欢它。
I'm sure I would feel that way if I wasn't. I love turning it on anytime I see it. Anytime I see it on TV, I watch it. It's so good. You're so good in that movie. You've never sucked. Everything you do, you're great in. So I would imagine a lot of people,
我相信如果我不是，我也会有那种感觉。我喜欢随时打开它，只要我看到它。只要我在电视上看到它，我就看。它太好了。你在那部电影里太棒了。你从来没烂过。你做的每一件事，你都很棒。所以我可以想象很多人，
you've been a part of a lot of really great things that are very cool in the comedy world. And it's something you should, I'm sure you do really are proud of. Well, likewise. And you know, the part of that, when I was talking earlier about that, kind of figuring it out when we started Party Down,
你参与了很多非常棒的事情，在喜剧界非常酷。这是你应该，我相信你确实为此感到自豪。好吧，同样。你知道，那部分，当我早些时候谈到那个时，当我们开始《派对之后》时，那种弄清楚的感觉，
the other part of that that I was gonna get to was when I was telling someone about the show, I forget who it was, I was like, yeah, it's this catering team and I'm kind of at the center of it and I'm not sure what to do. And they're like, oh, you're at the center of it? Like Bateman on Arrested Development.
我要说的另一部分是，当我告诉某人关于这个节目时，我忘了是谁了，我当时说，是的，这是这个餐饮团队，我处于中心，我不确定该做什么。他们说，哦，你处于中心？就像《发展受阻》里的贝特曼。
Right, which is the craziness circling around him. Yes, and that was so key to kind of figuring it out, is watching, you know, I was watching the show anyway, but really thinking about it from that perspective was very key. Right, like how could you do, how could you be, how could you be as sort of charmless, and be emotionless, how could you suck all the charisma,
没错，也就是疯狂围绕着他。是的，这对于弄清楚它非常关键，是看着，你知道，我无论如何都在看这个节目，但真正从那个角度思考它非常关键。没错，就像你怎么能做，你怎么能，你怎么能表现得那么没魅力，而且没感情，你怎么能吸走所有的魅力，
yeah, charisma-less, and just be a blank mayonnaise Charmless and emotionless. How can you suck all the charisma, charisma-less and just be a blank mayonnaise on mayonnaise on egg? Thank you, Will. Well, what an inspiration. Happy to provide some sort of guidance. Adam, we love you, thank you for being here today. Guys, thank you for having me.
是的，没魅力，只是一个空白的蛋黄酱……没魅力和没感情。你怎么能吸走所有的魅力，没魅力，只是一个空白的蛋黄酱……谢谢，威尔。好吧，真是个灵感。很高兴提供一些指导。亚当，我们爱你，谢谢你今天来到这里。伙计们，谢谢你们邀请我。
Such a fan of the show. Yeah, that's really cool. Adam, love you., thank you for being here today. Guys, thank you for having me. Such a fan of the show. Yeah, that's really cool. Adam, love you, Adam. Love you guys. Please pass on our regards to Naomi. Yeah. Thank you. Yeah. Thank you. Yeah, thanks for doing this.
我是这个节目的粉丝。是的，那真的很酷。亚当，爱你。谢谢你今天来到这里。伙计们，谢谢你们邀请我。我是这个节目的粉丝。是的，那真的很酷。亚当，爱你，亚当。爱你们。请代我们向娜奥米问好。是的。谢谢。是的。谢谢。是的，谢谢你做这个。
Please tell Abel and Archie, I doubt they remember me, but please tell them hello. They're like full teenagers now. They are full teenagers. I will, JB ran into, Abe texted me from school. That's how I knew JB. And he's like, I just ran into Jason and he grabbed my ear. And I was like, yeah, that sounds about right.
请告诉阿贝尔和阿奇，我怀疑他们还记得我，但请告诉他们你好。他们现在是完全的青少年了。他们是完全的青少年。我会的，JB遇到了，阿贝从学校给我发短信。这就是我认识JB的方式。他说，我刚遇到杰森，他抓住了我的耳朵。我就说，是的，听起来很像。
Yeah. And you know, they are such big fans. I can say this. They're such big fans of yours and of Parks and Rec, even though it's their mom's show. During the pandemic, we watched, Abe and I watched all these episodes, like most of them, Parks and Rec, again,
是的。而且你知道，他们是如此大的粉丝。我可以这么说。他们是你的超级粉丝，也是《公园与游憩》的粉丝，尽管那是他们妈妈的节目。在疫情期间，我们看了，阿贝和我看了所有这些剧集，大部分，再次看了《公园与游憩》，
watched it all the way through. And then I would say to Amy like, hey, that episode was really good. Right, super high like that. Yeah, like eight years later. My kids have yet to see Parks and Rec, they're just, they don't care at all. Do they?
一直看完。然后我会对艾米说，嘿，那一集真的很好。没错，超级高，像那样。是的，像八年后。我的孩子们还没看过《公园与游憩》，他们只是，他们根本不在乎。他们看吗？
I don't know, your kids are like mine. They don't watch anything that we do. Nothing. They haven't watched Arrested Development. Never. And Abe loves comedy. Well neither has Sean, right? No, Sean's never watched it.
我不知道，你的孩子像我的。他们不看我们做的任何东西。什么都不看。他们没看过《发展受阻》。从来没看过。而且阿贝喜欢喜剧。好吧，肖恩也没看过，对吧？不，肖恩从来没看过。
And he is one of our children. So wait, Abe and Archie have not watched Arrested? No, and their friends have, and they're like, Abe was like, a lot of my friends love Bojack Horseman. We're going to strap these kids down one goddamn day. They should watch Arrested and they should watch BoJack Horseman, that would be so. And Parks and Rec, we're gonna strap them down
而且他是我们的孩子之一。等等，阿贝和阿奇没看过《发展受阻》？不，他们的朋友看过，他们就像，阿贝说，我的很多朋友喜欢《马男波杰克》。我们总有一天要把这些孩子绑起来。他们应该看《发展受阻》，他们应该看《马男波杰克》，那会非常。还有《公园与游憩》，我们要把他们绑起来
and they will respect us. Amy kind of guilted them into it though, if I'm being honest. If I'm being totally honest. That sounds like not bad. In a way that only Polar can, you know. Okay fine, don't watch it, you know. Your choice.
他们会尊重我们的。不过说实话，艾米有点内疚地让他们看了。如果我完全诚实的话。听起来不错。以一种只有波拉能做到的方式，你知道。好吧，算了，别看它，你知道。你的选择。
Adam, thank you, dude. Guys, thank you. Love you, buddy. Great to see you, love you too. Bye, bye, take it easy. Now that feels like we kind of deprived the audience of a really good interview because it just felt like we were just sitting on the couch
亚当，谢谢你，伙计。伙计们，谢谢。爱你，哥们。很高兴见到你，我也爱你。再见，再见，放轻松。现在感觉我们好像剥夺了观众一次非常好的采访，因为感觉我们只是坐在沙发上
he's over here at one of our homes like he always is and I feel like we were undisciplined, I was, and we were all just a bunch of bullshit not really asking questions. You know what, no, it's like the Catherine Hahn episode where a good friend comes on and we just kind of chit chat. Yeah, just a bunch of bullshit. We apologize, listener.
他像往常一样在我们其中一个家里，我觉得我们纪律涣散，我是，我们都只是一堆胡扯，并没有真正问问题。你知道吗，不，这就像凯瑟琳·哈恩那一集，一个好朋友来了，我们只是闲聊。是的，只是一堆胡扯。我们道歉，听众。
We're just children holding our breath. Adam likes to fuck around and do bits and joke around, and so why not? Yeah. I mean, it must have been like that on Will and Grace. Oh. I love it. Everybody's gay.
我们只是屏住呼吸的孩子。亚当喜欢胡闹，做片段，开玩笑，所以为什么不呢？是的。我的意思是，在《威尔和格蕾丝》上一定也是那样。哦。我喜欢它。每个人都是同性恋。
Everybody's gay! I finally feel good about my sexuality! I feel safe to come out now! Please let me out! Can I sit closer to the stage now? I'm in here! Just let me out! Can I sit closer to the stage now? I mean, I mean here. I can't see anything from back here. That is so funny. That is so great. Hey, but listen, at the end of the day,
每个人都是同性恋！我终于对我的性取向感觉良好！我觉得出柜很安全！请让我出去！我现在可以坐得离舞台更近吗？我在这里！只是让我出去！我现在可以坐得离舞台更近吗？我的意思是，我的意思是这里。我从后面什么也看不见。那太搞笑了。那太棒了。嘿，但听着，归根结底，
at the end of the day, you need people like Adam Scott. Oh, good for you to bring it back. Look at you, what a response was Stuart in our show. I'm trying to talk slowly here as I try to think up a buy. No, I got one. So by having, okay, by having Adam in our world, socially, professionally, what Sean? It's wonderful, it's wonderful.
归根结底，你需要像亚当·斯科特这样的人。哦，你把它带回来真是太好了。看看你，在我们的节目里是什么回应。我试着慢慢说，因为我试着想出一个再见。不，我有一个。所以通过拥有，好的，通过在我们的世界里拥有亚当，社交上，职业上，肖恩？这太美妙了，这太美妙了。
It's like what your Italian friend would say, ciao, but we would say, bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Smart. Less. Smart.
就像你的意大利朋友会说的，Ciao，但我们会说，再见。再见。再见。再见。聪明。少。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Granteri. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。SmartLess是由Rob Armgerve、Bennett Barbico和Michael Granteri手工制作的100%有机节目。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。